هذه هي مسقط رأسي منذ أربعة أشهر
الآن في قبضة العملية المؤيدة للديمقراطية
التي تم إخفاء الكثير منها بوحشية عن
العالم من قبل حكومة السودان ، ومع ذلك
لا يزال الناس هنا يخاطرون بكل شيء من
أجل التغيير حتى في الوقت الذي تعمل فيه الولايات المتحدة من
خلال العلاقات الدبلوماسية
مع السودان.  الحكومة بشدة على
العاصمة السودانية حيث كنت نشأت هنا ، كانت
قبضة الحكومة على شعبها
تشمل حقًا ، لكن ارتفاع
تكلفة المعيشة في السنوات الأخيرة
أثار احتجاجات ضد أحد
أقدم الديكتاتوريين في العالم ، وهو
الرئيس عمر البشير السوداني.
الحكومة لا تريد أن
يعرف العالم ما يحدث ، أي صحفي
يتم ضبطه أثناء تغطيته للمظاهرات
يخاطر بالسجن مدى الحياة وعقوبة
الإعدام في الحشد أحاول التراجع
والتصوير بالكاميرات السرية
والهواتف الذكية وآمل ألا
أرصد
بعضًا من  بدأ المتظاهرون في الصراخ
بأن عملاء الأمن القومي في
طريقهم عملاء مشهورون بوحشيتهم
علينا أن  ترك عائلة توافق على
إخفائنا في ما يسميه الناس هنا منزلًا آمنًا ،
ولكنه في الحقيقة مجرد منزل لشخص ما ،
وقد وصل عملاء الأمن القومي ،
وقاموا بتفريق المظاهرة
التي كانوا يذهبون إليها من منزل إلى منزل.
منزل آمن حيث
يحاولون معرفة كيفية
الخروج من هذا الصوت الذي تسمعه
مدافع الغاز المسيل للدموع ، لقد حوصرنا لساعات
لا يمكننا إلا أن نشاهدها ونستمع إليها من
خلال فجوة في النافذة
المجاورة لنا مباشرة يقوم رجال الأمن بالصفع
و  ركل أحد المتظاهرين وهم
يسحبونه إلى الخارج ابن الجيران في النهاية ،
تركنا معداتنا خلفنا ونخاطر بالهرب ،
كنا محظوظين
لكن كثيرين آخرين لم تجمع سي إن إن
شهادات مفصلة من معتقلين سابقين
محتجزين في مرافق الحكومة السودانية في أوفر.
3000 شخص تم
اعتقالهم منذ بدء المظاهرات
يقولون جميعهم تقريبًا إنهم تعرضوا لسوء
المعاملة أحدهم يوافق على التحدث إلينا كولا
بلا مأوى ، أعني أنه وقت موسيلين كاراتيه
صودا
مينتو في بابا واوا فادهاك
وحيد انظر لمن يمتلك ماندير فاريل بوب
واجهة جديدة آسف نسيت
محفظتك لتمشي بضعة كيلومترات إذا كنت
تعمل ، لماذا يا الأم المسكينة 11 هي
نادلة الفانيليا ،
منازل الأشباح الجاسوسة ، منازل التعذيب التي
تقول الحكومة إنها غير موجودة ، ذهبنا إلى
حاول العثور على واحد لنا جميعًا الذين
نشأوا في ظل ديكتاتورية البشير ،
تستحضر بيوت الأشباح على الفور
أهوال هذه الحكومة المتهمة
بالتعذيب والاعتداء الجنسي والضرب الوحشي
في وسط هوثورن ، ونجد
تواجدًا عسكريًا واستخباراتيًا كثيفًا
على يسارك.  خارج
المربع ، أخبرنا ناشط ممسك بقلم تم التقاطه
في وسط المدينة أنه تم ضرب
الشعر وفرزه وفقًا لجريمتنا المزعومة ،
لا يمكننا البقاء في كل مكان.
منازل الأشباح المنتشرة في جميع أنحاء
المدينة باستخدام الأوصاف التي قدمها لنا
شهود العيان والنشطاء المحتجزون سابقًا
هناك تمكنوا من تحديد مكان واحد باستخدام
الصور الجوية جنوب بلو.  e
Nile in Garden City راقب
هذا المبنى الأخضر
، وشاهدنا التقاطات للأمن القومي وما
بدا أنه محتجزون
أسوأ على الرغم من وجود العديد من
المحتجزين الذين قابلناهم وصفوا تعرضهم
للتعذيب عبر النهر هنا في
ما يعرف
بالثلاجة الأكبر  إنه اسم يلهم
الرعب ومع ذلك وافقت امرأة واحدة على التحدث
إلينا وهو ليس الله ، ليس لدي ما يكفي
على باب منزلي وأضيف جميل شخصًا
عندما لم أعرض عليك تمامًا
بعض المشكلات الاقتصادية العربية إما
زوجي  جاء زوجي بيجي فارسيتي
سيغنا بخير ، فأنا لم أفعل ماكومبر التشيلي ،
فلماذا على الرغم من كل هذه
إدارة الرئيس ترامب في محادثات
لإعادة العلاقات مع السودان ، فهذه هي
الآثار الوحشية للهجمات الإرهابية
على يو إس إس كول والسفارات الأمريكية في  شرق
إفريقيا لسنوات ، كانت عائلات
الضحايا تسعى للحصول على تعويضات من
الحكومة السودانية التي يعتقدون أنها
متواطئة ، علمت سي إن إن أن أحد
المتطلبات الرئيسية للمحادثات يراهن  وين السودان
والولايات المتحدة.  هو أن يدخل السودان في
مفاوضات بحسن نية فيما يتعلق
بتعويض أسر الضحايا في
بيان وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
لا تنفي استمرار المحادثات مع
السودان أو أن هذا يتعلق في
النهاية بمزاعم الإرهاب ، لكنها تقول إن العلاقات
ستتحسن فقط إذا اتخذت الحكومة السودانية
الخطوات المتعلقة بحقوق الإنسان
لم يُظهر السودانيون أي بوادر على
فعل ذلك ، ومع ذلك تستمر المحادثات لتحسين
العلاقات بعد أيام من
البحث ، يمكننا التحقق من أن
ابن الجيران الذي صورناه أثناء
احتجازه لم يُطلق سراحه إلا بعد ساعات
من التعذيب ، كما يقول.  شاهده هنا
ضحية أخرى في سلسلة
ضحايا القمع الوحشي في السودان
[موسيقى]
هذا ما شهدناه في يوم واحد فقط في
الوطن المظاهرات
الغاز المسيل للدموع الخوف لكن
الأهوال استمرت لفترة أطول ولم
يكن هناك حتى الآن  نهاية في الأفق